Hi, I’m Carrie Anne, and welcome to CrashCourse
Computer Science!
Over the past five episodes, we’ve worked
up from text-based teletype interfaces to
pixelated bitmapped graphics. Then, last episode,
we covered Graphical User Interfaces and all
their “Ooey Gooey” richness.
All of these examples have been 2D. But of
course “we are living in a 3D world, and
I’m a 3 dimensional girl!”
So today, we're going to talk about some fundamental
methods in 3D computer graphics and how you
render them onto a 2D screen.
INTRO
As we discussed in episode 24 we can write functions that draw a line between any two points like A and B.
By manipulating the X and Y coordinates of
points A and B, we can manipulate the line.
In 3D graphics, points have not just two coordinates,
but three -- X, Y and Z. Or “zee” but
I’m going to say “zed”.
Of course, we don’t have X/Y/Z coordinates
on a 2D computer screen, so graphics algorithms
are responsible for “flattening” 3D coordinates
onto a 2D plane.
This process is known as 3D Projection. Once
all of the points have been converted from
3D to 2D, we can use the regular 2D line drawing
function to connect the dots… literally.
This is called Wireframe Rendering.
Imagine building a cube out of chopsticks,
and shining a flashlight on it. The shadow
it casts onto your wall – its projection
– is flat. If you rotate the cube around,
you can see it’s a 3D object, even though
it’s a flat projection.
This transformation from 3D to 2D is exactly
what your computer is doing, just with a lot
more math… and less chopsticks.
There are several types of 3D Projection.
What you’re seeing right now is an Orthographic
Projection, where, for example, the parallel
sides in the cube appear as parallel in the
projection.
In the real 3D world through, parallel lines
converge as they get further from the viewer,
like a road going to the horizon. This type
of 3D projection is called Perspective Projection.
It’s the same process, just with different
math. Sometimes you want perspective and sometimes
you don’t -- the choice is up to the developer.
Simple shapes, like cubes, are easily defined
by straight lines. But for more complex shapes,
triangles are better -- what are called polygons
in 3D graphics.
Look at this beautiful teapot made out of
polygons. A collection of polygons like this
is a mesh.
The denser the mesh, the smoother the curves
and the finer the details. But, that also
increases the polygon count, which means more
work for the computer.
Game designers have to carefully balance model
fidelity vs. polygon count, because if the
count goes too high, the framerate of an animation
drops below what users perceive as smooth.
For this reason, there are algorithms for
simplifying meshes.
The reason triangles are used, and not squares,
or polygons, or some other more complex shape
is simplicity: three points in space unambiguously
define a plane.
If you give me three points in a 3D space,
I can draw a plane through it - there is only
one.. single.. answer.
This isn’t guaranteed to be true for shapes
with four or more points. Also, two points
aren’t enough to define a plane, only a
line, so three is the perfect and minimal
number. Triangles for the win!
Wireframe rendering is cool and all – sorta
retro – but of course 3D graphics can also
be filled.
The classic algorithm for doing this is called
Scanline Rendering, first developed in 1967
at the University of Utah. For a simple example,
let’s consider just one polygon.
Our job here is to figure out how this polygon
translates to filled pixels on a computer
screen, so let’s first overlay a grid of
pixels to fill.
The scanline algorithm starts by reading the
three points that make up the polygon, and
finding the lowest and highest Y values. It
will only consider rows between these two
points.
Then, the algorithm works down one row at
a time. In each row, it calculates where a
line – running through the center of a row
– intersects with the side of the polygon.
Because polygons are triangles, if you intersect
one line, you have to intersect with another.
It’s guaranteed! The job of the scanline
algorithm is to fill in the pixels between
the two intersections. Let’s see how this
works.
On the first row we look at we intersect here
and here.
The algorithm then colors in all pixels between
those two intersections.
And this just continues, row by row, which
is why it’s called Scan... Line... Rendering.
When we hit the bottom of the polygon, we’re
done. The rate at which a computer fills in
polygons is called the fillrate.
Admittedly, this is a pretty ugly filled polygon.
It has what are known as “Jaggies” -- those
rough edges. This effect is less pronounced
when using smaller pixels. But nonetheless,
you see these in games all the time, especially
on lower powered platforms.
One method to soften this effect is Antialiasing.
Instead of filling pixels in a polygon with
the same color, we can adjust the color based
on how much the polygon cuts through each
pixel.
If a pixel is entirely inside of a polygon,
it gets fully colored. But if the polygon
only grazes a pixel, it’ll get a lighter
shade. This feathering of the edges is much
more pleasant to the eyes.
Antialiasing is used all over the place, including
in 2D graphics, like fonts and icons. If you
lean in real close to your monitor.. Closer…
closer…. Closer!
You’ll see all the fonts in your browser
are Antialiased. So smooth!
In a 3D scene, there are polygons that are
part objects in the back, near the front,
and just about everywhere. Only some are visible,
because some objects are hidden behind other
objects in the scene -- what’s called occlusion.
The most straightforward way to handle this
is to use a sort algorithm, and arrange all
the polygons in the scene from farthest to
nearest, then render them in that order.
This is called the Painter's Algorithm, because
painters also have to start with the background,
and then increasingly work up to foreground
elements.
Consider this example scene with three overlapping
polygons.
To make things easier to follow, we’re going
to color the polygons differently. Also for
simplicity, we’ll assume these polygons
are all parallel to the screen, but in a real
program, like a game, the polygons can be
tilted in 3D space.
Our three polygons, A B and C… are at distance
20, 12 and 14.
The first thing the Painter’s Algorithm
does is sort all the polygons, from farthest
to nearest.
Now that they’re in order, we can use scanline
rendering to fill each polygon, one at a time.
We start with Polygon A, the farthest one
away.
Then we repeat the process for the next farthest
polygon, in this case, C.
And then we repeat this again, for Polygon
B.
Now we’re all done, and you can see the
ordering is correct. The polygons that are
closer, are in front!
An alternative method for handling occlusion
is called Z-Buffering. It achieves the same
output as before, but with a different algorithm.
Let’s go back to our previous example, before
it was sorted. That’s because this algorithm
doesn’t need to sort any polygons, which
makes it faster.
In short, Z-buffering keeps track of the closest
distance to a polygon for every pixel in the
scene. It does this by maintaining a Z-Buffer,
which is just a matrix of values that sits
in memory.
At first, every pixel is initialized to infinity.
Then Z-buffering starts with the first polygon
in its list. In this case, that’s A.
It follows the same logic as the scanline
algorithm, but instead of coloring in pixels,
it checks the distance of the polygon versus
what’s recorded in its Z-Buffer.
It records the lower of the two values. For
our Polygon A, with a distance of 20, it wins
against infinity every time.
When it’s done with Polygon A, it moves
on to the next polygon in its list, and the
same thing happens.
Now, because we didn’t sort the polygons,
it’s not always the case that later polygons
overwrite high values. In the case of Polygon
C, only some of the values in the Z-buffer
get new minimum distances.
This completed Z-buffer is used in conjunction
with a fancier version of scanline rendering
that not only tests for line intersection,
but also does a lookup to see if that pixel
will even be visible in the final scene. If
it’s not, the algorithm skips it and moves
on.
An interesting problem arises when two polygons
have the same distance, like if Polygon A
and B are both at a distance of 20. Which
one do you draw on top?
Polygons are constantly being shuffled around
in memory and changing their access order.
Plus, rounding errors are inherent in floating
point computations. So, which one gets drawn
on top is often unpredictable.
The result is a flickering effect called Z-Fighting,
which if you’ve played 3D games, you’ve
no doubt encountered.
Speaking of glitches, another common optimization
in 3D graphics is called Back-Face Culling.
If you think about it, a triangle has two
sides, a front and a back. With something
like the head of an avatar, or the ground
in a game, you should only ever see one side
-- the side facing outwards.
So to save processing time, the back-side
of polygons are often ignored in the rendering
pipeline, which cuts the number of polygon
faces to consider in half.
This is great, except when there’s a bug
that lets you get inside of those objects,
and look outwards. Then the avatar head or
ground becomes invisible.
Moving on. We need to talk about lighting
-- also known as shading -- because if it’s
a 3D scene, the lighting should vary over
the surface of objects.
Let’s go back to our teapot mesh.
With scanline rendering coloring in all the
polygons, our teapot looks like this. Not
very 3D.
So, let’s add some lighting to enhance the
realism!
As an example, we’ll pick 3 polygons from
different parts of our teapot.
Unlike our previous examples, we’re now
going to consider how these polygons are oriented
in 3D space -- they’re no longer parallel
to the screen, but rather tilted in different
3D directions.
The direction they face is called the Surface
Normal, and we can visualize that direction
with a little 3D arrow that’s perpendicular
to the polygon’s surface.
Now let’s add a light source.
Each polygon is going to be illuminated a
different amount. Some will appear brighter,
because their angle causes more light to be
reflected towards the viewer.
For example, the bottom-most polygon is tilted
downwards, away from the light source, which
means it’s going to be dark.
In a similar way, the rightmost polygon is
slightly facing away from the light, so it
will be partially illuminated.
And finally, there’s the upper-left polygon.
Its angle means that it will reflect light
from the light source towards our view.
So, it’ll appear bright.
If we do this for every polygon, our teapot
looks like this which is much more realistic!
This approach is called Flat Shading, and
it’s the most basic lighting algorithm.
Unfortunately, it also makes all those polygon
boundaries really noticeable and the mesh
doesn’t look smooth.
For this reason, more advanced lighting algorithms
were developed, such as Gouraud Shading and
Phong Shading. Instead of coloring in polygons
using just one colour, they vary the colour
across the surface in clever ways, which results
in much nicer output.
We also need to talk about textures, which
in graphics refers to the look of a surface,
rather than its feel.
Like with lighting, there are many algorithms
with all sorts of fancy effects. The simplest
is texture mapping. To visualize this process,
let’s go back to our single polygon.
When we’re filling this in, using scanline
rendering, we can look up what color to use
at every pixel according to a texture image
saved in memory. To do this, we need a mapping
between the polygon’s coordinates and the
texture’s coordinates.
Let’s jump to the first pixel that scanline
rendering needs to fill in.
The texturing algorithm will consult the texture
in memory, take the average color from the
corresponding region, and fill the polygon
accordingly.
This process repeats for all pixels in the
polygon, and that’s how we get textures.
If you combine all the techniques we’ve
talked about this episode, you get a wonderfully
funky little teapot.
And this teapot can sit in an even bigger
scene, comprised of millions of polygons.
Rendering a scene like this takes a fair amount
of computation. But importantly, it’s the
same type of calculations being performed
over and over and over again for many millions
of polygons – scanline filling, antialiasing,
lighting, and texturing. However there are
a couple of ways to make this much faster!
First off, we can speed things up by having
special hardware with extra bells and whistles
just for these specific types of computations,
making them lightning fast. And secondly,
we can divide up a 3D scene into many smaller
parts, and then render all the pieces in parallel,
rather than sequentially.
CPU’s aren’t designed for this, so they
aren’t particularly fast. So, computer engineers
created special processors just for graphics
– a GPU, or Graphics Processing Unit.
These can be found on graphics cards inside
of your computer, along with RAM reserved
for graphics. This is where all the meshes
and textures live, allowing them to be accessed
super fast by many different cores of the
GPU all at once.
A modern graphics card, like a GeForce GTX
1080 TI, contains 3584 processing cores, offering
massive parallelization. It can process hundreds
of millions of polygons every second!
Ok, that concludes our whistle stop tour of
3D graphics. Next week, we switch topics entirely.
I’ll ping you then.